then we're out here with a couple of new
up-and-coming property investors we've
got five properties that all the markets
look at today and hopefully by the end
of the day when I found a full bedroom
HMO for less than 100 grams that is in
good condition so it's gonna be a good
day
how you been doing excited takes to
learn so qiji posters the room and we've
just come out with Julie Julie what do
you think of the specs of hey Jeanette
what are your impressions would you live
here yes do we go guys
beautiful bad picture so we've just
viewed a really good house it's on 490
and we're gonna make an offer of 81 500
it's in good condition it's in
Wolverhampton city center it's got four
massive rooms to the rooms in humongous
but they're all good-sized rooms so
let's see how we get on
how's it going yes if you want to see us
view and buy more houses in real life
like this and don't forget to Like share
and subscribe and the more you do that
the more we will film if you're also
interested in investing yourself and
getting crazy high returns then don't
forget go down to
www.investlocalbook.com